hello my name is Pamela laughs I'm vice
president for Latin America and the
Caribbean the World Bank and the
question I wanted an answer today is how
can you get involved in development this
is something that we've been thinking
about at the mural thing because after
all you are the future of the region
Luther the future of the world and you
bring such exciting ideas to the table I
want to give you an example of what
happened on 80 we're actually it was our
young staff who figured out that one of
the best ways to evaluate the impact of
the earthquake was to do it through an
open source platform that we did with
Google and we have a hundred
institutions around the world helping us
to evaluate the Earth's a compact we
never would have followed this without
the use so increasingly what we want to
do is
you want to bring in the ideas of youth
and if you want to make sure that
development is having a positive impact
on you so
part of development and youth needs to
be a beneficiary of development
increasingly we at the World Bank have
not increasingly we do have a policy to
completely open access to information so
we encourage you to use social media
both in your countries on and globally
to start asking questions and getting
involved at any level at the community
level in the national level and that
and thank you for caring